u.s capitol police officer brian siknik
who was killed in last month's riot at
the capitol lies in honor this morning
he died the day after good morning
officer bryant stiknick's arrival at the
capitol was a powerful reminder of the
toll of violence last month
inside the capitol including in the
rotunda where he lies
this morning it's also a measure of the
lives lost chris van cleave is on
capitol hill where the leaders of the
house
and the senate plan to pay tribute to
officer stiknick
chris good morning to you tony good
morning
it was a very powerful moment as the
hearse arrived outside the east front of
the capitol here
i want to show you some video from that
powerful and
solemn moment if we can now this is the
public memorial for officer brian siknik
he is a former service member who
deployed to battle enemies abroad only
to be killed defending
a symbol of democracy at home the urn
carrying the 42 year old's remains
was placed in the rotunda rioters
stormed four weeks ago
lying in honor at the capitol is
considered a sacred tribute
officer siknik is only the fifth private
citizen to lie in the rotunda
president biden and the first lady also
came to pay their respects along with
his capital police
counterparts members of congress
including congressional leaders did as
well
now later today there will be a
ceremonial departure
from the capitol here officer siknik
will be taken to arlington national
cemetery where he'll be laid to rest
gail thank you very much chris